yeah I mean we took register raised in
LA he's here he's visiting we go down to
to Nobu in Malibu which is a sushi
obviously a hot spot in Malibu right on
the water beautiful
we don't have reservations when go in
we're like do you have anything for two
they go yeah the sushi bar like face
face the wall you to face the wall
logics the rapper is walking out of
there I would not even even know who he
is until right number one he's white and
I know that he says the n-word a lot
because he has a black parent god bless
him but it's your white so whatever but
I get it and he walks out like you know
and I'm like God good for him and then
he wasn't saying the n-word in noble I'm
just saying I've noticed that you know
he has that lice that was you and I
don't know it was me that was me and we
go in there and and and ray first of all
it's no longer sunset it's dark you
can't see anything
no booze like infested with celebrities
and other people that don't want to be
like filmed ray does the craziest thing
I've ever seen in my life
he swivels around in the chair at the
sushi bar which by the way they put us
into sushi bar to face the wall so that
nobody would have to see us eating
forbidden fish cuz you know what sushi
is you slurping with your fingers yeah
and nobody nobody needs to see ray or
myself playing with soy sauce you know
so they go face the wall he turns around
with his phone and starts filming the
restaurants it's absolutely true you
know that's what you're laughing
it's [ __ ] horror show first of all
where we're conspicuous in there already
I'm not a low profile keep it low keep
it low he turns out with his phone and
he's our driver and I go what the [ __ ]
are you doing I see you can't do this
this is crazy gonna try to tell everyone
what happened as a preface you've taken
me very nice restaurant I've never you
know you've never done this before I may
be the famous me lost your mind
I don't go out my way introduce myself
of people you had a moment of temporary
insanity with this I was only thinking
about my girlfriend Lucy
okay that's sweet but she's like shoot
them where you to film a restaurant no
magic is I understand that they're just
regular people I think if it would have
been wrong in a sizzler which we were in
earlier next to the fat store if you
took out a phone in a sizzler and did
that it would be also wrong and probably
criminal I understand that a man such as
yourself should not be filming people in
a restaurant it was a picture was
filming not a documentary I wasn't
trying to get like some I wouldn't try
to do some brown and pedophilia
documentary in Nobu I'm just [ __ ]
trying like you know get like the woods
very nice here I understand what you're
trying to do but it was a moment of
temporary session you were completely
insane
I forgot about this place be if we mean
you could just walk in because we've
talked about it before nice restaurants
are the only thing that can't legally
keep us out right
that's why food is our only luxury we've
discussed this before people say why do
you like nice red wouldn't you let me in
your Country Club with that and I won't
be as fat I can't go anywhere else
I can't get on someone's jet I can't
just waltz in to bel-air and walk
through the gates and enjoy myself the
only thing that so far legally they
cannot stop me and you from doing is
going to a nice restaurant it is the
only luxury for the poor I get beaten up
on fatty I'm not that positive fat
activist I get it it's bad for you of
cause diabetes I know everybody's trying
to be better out there maybe some people
aren't but whatever none of us are happy
being fat that's the other thing how
many people are actually happy being fat
not a lot you know some people are can
tend to be slobs sure but like this
whole idea that there's a lot of people
being like I'm fat and deal with it it's
just not how it's gross I mean the
billionaires are doing it but not people
bus nobody on a public bus is thrilled
to be a fat ass ya know it wants it
nobody want nobody who's poor and fat is
like look at this [ __ ] it's called
confidence no no one's doing that in a
Walmart what it is is millionaires who
are like just gonna put it out there and
make money doing it well it's really
also keep eating our poison right you
know it's like hey you'll put down that
macaroni and cheese fatty yeah
swallow it yeah it's just that like that
there's an interest in this whatever
they want you eating salad like who
would the dole corporation is not the
biggest consortium and for bits about it
we were raised a lot of our generation
and it doesn't this doesn't justify
eating this [ __ ] now and it doesn't
justify not changing your life but our
and I've said it before and I say it on
stage our boomer parents fed us poison
we were the fast food generation right
in a way that kids growing up today are
not I mean we were we were people at
birthday parties in fast food places are
there are formative years well before
even supersize me which was right there
was a big turning point where they
started to at least show they try with
it was there was a level of shame we're
like that we're gonna make sounds more
prominent and we're gonna try like I was
on that guy's podcast par lock and they
didn't he to himself and no one can
remember that yeah he went out there and
he's like I've acted in a propensity but
you feel like as much as I didn't do
anything to fast food yeah there was
still a level of like yet you're still
gonna eat this stuff fatty but like I
they weren't even showing salad I mean
if we're kids don't even have them and
then like when they had the salad shaker
yeah there was like a shank
make sure you he's poor like you know
three-quarters of his distress but a guy
that says make this [ __ ] illegal or
whatever but I am saying when your kid
and you grow up in these environment
eating this type of food it is it is not
good and I feel like a lot of kids today
aren't because people are more educated
now right about food
they're more educated but it is a luxury
for the poor food is a luxury for poor
people
it's the one thing you can do it mean
even
even a nice Kraft macaroni and cheese
it's a nice shut up
now you're now you're going on that's
McDonnell not gonna cosign that why what
I'm saying
but buttering it he's a bit bugger what
I'm saying is stop stop talking about
Kraft macaroni and cheese jesus [ __ ]
christ my point is that even a poor
person can can wrangle enough money to
go put a stake in their throat would be
like steak and a baked potato in there
throw if there's no McDonald's be well
know that McDonald's really isn't a
luxury ok it's a necessity I guess for
certain people whatever but my point is
that that's why you will you go to Nobu
they can't keep us out they can't they
can't you know when we walk in here they
can't go excuse me you think us in a
back room and beat the [ __ ] out of us
sure they can't do that yet yet it's
coming